yeah I grew up with a lot I just had
someone saying society man everything
man you know I don't talk about anxiety
that much and I think because some of my
anxiety is going away from once I got an
a a program or I started finding
recovery for myself or seeking out forms
to make myself feel better but dude I
had ain't I had anxiousness as a child I
had anxiety and I think part of the
reason I had so much anxiety as a child
was because I was I was breastfed on a
cups my mother had them baby A's you
know when it came when it came time for
you know on them tea toss my mom had
them at coops you know then baby a cups
and for a baby when you trying to
breastfeed when you were when you were a
baby and you're breastfeeding I don't
know if there's anything more anxious
looking then a baby trying to breastfeed
off of a cup because you're trying to
get all that let's say you know you're
trying to hit that you know just
straight-up catch that that DNA you know
that DNA uh you know you're trying to
catch that just jowl up with that milky
milky offset and you can't get enough
you can't get it you're trying to rattle
that milk out of a little a cup come on
and that's today and that's just you
know as a baby you're just trying to
rattle that a cup but Dean I don't care
how much you rattle there ain't enough
during them there ain't much you know
there ain't much sauce in that in that
dish if your mom got them small breasts
and look I love my mother you know and
I'm not a discredit in her my saying
there's anything wrong with my mother at
all
I respect my mother's body it was
beautiful body you know my mother's
always taking care of her body and I've
always thought that my mother was a
beautiful woman but damn boy when you
were a child and you got a rattle you
trying to rattle some milk out of an
a-cup you know that's like trying to
beat a couple sips of you know a punch
out of a out of an empty a capri-sun
sack can man can you do it and that
rattle what I'm saying is that rattle as
a baby that rattle never leaves your
body that shaking shaking shaking
rattling
you know beatin your hands against a
small a cup breast trying to get a sip
of you know that body guava that never
leaves you
and so I know joke I have a theory that
a lot of my anxiety and a lot of anxiety
out there comes from children who were
raised and breastfed off them small a
cup breasts because you never forget
that just that constant just but nothing
very little in there maybe you catch a
drop you know when your mom leans over
to look at something maybe you catch a
you know a quarter Grammy in the back of
your throat but very little in the
makeups very very little and that rattle
that desperation never really leaves you
the uncomfort because as a baby you're
really putting yourself out there when
you think about it when you're sucking
on a breast or a you know a teddy you
know some people call them Teddy's
especially like if you're in Scotland
like oh look at the look at the Teddy's
I'm gonna you know if you if you are you
know you know if you gumming up on a
breast or a teat or a teddy
then you you're putting yourself out
there you know as a baby you know as a
baby you're putting yourself out there
man because you know other babies might
be around they might be relaxing maybe
the dog is in the room maybe your dad's
in the room or a sibling and you're
gonna just try it you're gonna I mean
you're not it's not like you're waiting
by our microwave you're sucking on that
heater when you're breastfeeding as a
baby you know I'm saying you just put in
your face and just taking all the
chances that's exposing yourself that's
putting yourself out there
Just Giving is sucking a stay alive and
the fact that nothing might come out and
that's embarrassing then people got to
look around and see your cheeks ain't
filling up and I think I went through a
lot of that you know and my brother had
also gotten to my mother's breast before
me he was older than me and he was born
before me and he breastfed before me and
I even remember one time when I even and
I vaguely vaguely remember this and some
of this memory is more in my bones than
it is in my brain but I vaguely remember
there being my brother elbowing me off
that breast you know I'm just kidding
you know just giving me that sharp you
know just that arm edge that elbow you
know just giving me that [ __ ] rep
that that natural right angle of the arm
that elbow and just you know nudging me
off that the top nudging me right off
Mama's top and taking that you know
maybe catching a couple you know
whatever last grams of milk was in there
and leaving me off that alecha and
that's it's just toughen so I think a
lot of my anxiety started then a lot of
my anxiety started then and some people
you know like you may you know and it
makes sense
it just makes such sense the struggle
because here's the other thing the other
babies was these fatty fatty babies and
they over there with a long eyelashes
because they got a lot of milk in them
and the milk is making you know parts of
their body grow and they got strong
bones and they got [ __ ] eat you know
they might have an ankle weighs you know
each one of their ankles now weighs a
couple ounces probably because they're
boning up their bodies narrowing up cuz
they converting that milk and they
looking all fat and unconscious one baby
had passed out and a lot of milk had
ruled out of his mouth and pulled up
around his eye he had that naughty white
eye patch you know that fat baby [ __ ]
eye patch when that that milk you know
they're they're sleeping at such an
angle where the milk rolls out of their
mouths and
just pulls up in their eye around their
eye on top of their closed eyelid and
they got that [ __ ] leche eye patch
you know and you're like Dan that fat
[ __ ] he have so much milk over by him
he [ __ ] he doing just tricks with it
he's doing with stunts this [ __ ]
over here David Blaine and under his
[ __ ] milk sleeping under half an
ounce and I'm out here judge just
fighting for every damn drip at a drap
drought I'm just saying that is the
struggle when your mother got a small
breast and you're trying to get that
natural that natural body sauce about it
you trying to get that you know that
there are that nurture that you trying
to get fed and that anxiety never leaves
you oh sorry I went off on that but that
[ __ ] bends me up a little bit because I
think about anxiety I think about how
anxiety gets baked in you as a child
here's another thing I think if you as a
lot of children you get anxiety because
you were conceived in a doggy style
position and a lot of people think
that's crazy and sorry I'm having a
little bit what I got me a second
cherries hmm and they're good I think
these are from Washington State well
we're actually Montana dude everybody
say different people have cherries and
stuff go to Montana then get you a sack
of them [ __ ] hitters boy mother
nature's g-spots right here boy
these Bing cherries come out my daddy
used to eat these at night and let me
hold the pits in my hand
if I was well-behaved but anyhow was
like my oh I think babies that were
conceived in the doggy style position
come out with severe anxiety because
that's pressure imagine you have of
course if you're conceived in doggy
style you feel like you got to put on a
show for the world and that's baked into
you whereas if you just said you know if
you just that casual just loitering just
missionary baby and you come out all
just loitering into the world just had
me scenario then yeah you're gonna have
a casual lifestyle but if you that net
that naughty daughter that pops out of a
doggy style conception Cameroon you
gonna be a tricky [ __ ] out in the world
cuz you're gonna be nervous because you
already feel like you have to put on a
show before you've even opened your eyes
or your soul to the world so it's crazy
how many things can happen how many
things can be baked into us that we
don't even realize you know how many
things can be that are just beyond us
you know and I say I guess some of this
stuff I've had a wild week man you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz it's
alarming